summer's here that means a lot of
vacations coming up but that could be a
problem for divorced parents
who might have a hard time agreeing on
travel plans
that is the topic of today's la vegas
now segment with eric palacios divorce
can be really tough eric for a lot of
parents
and there are a lot of questions that
come with it one is
can one parent take the kids out of
state without notifying the other
that's a great question one that comes
up a lot during these months uh during
the summer a lot of uh
parents plan vacations and they want to
go out to state
uh generally if you have custody
of the kids during your time or your
visitation days
you are free uh to take them out of
state
uh however it's always a good idea to
let your ex
know where you're going to be a lot of
parents will leave and let them know the
hotel they're gonna stay
the phone number uh just in case
anything happens or
there needs to be communication between
the children
uh and the other spouse uh that they
know where they're going to be
you said out of state does that mean
they have the right or do not have the
right to take the kids out of the
country
that's a little more difficult normally
that requires written permission
by your ex and
even the airlines will sometimes require
a notarized letter
birth certificates they want to be real
careful that you're not
leaving the country with the intent of
not coming back
we see that happen every now and then
and it's a horrible thing when when
one of the parents without permission
takes their kids out of the country and
then
trying to get the kids back and take
years sometimes so
that's a very long and painful process
so if you're going to take your kids out
of the
country you do need permission from the
other parent
in writing a notarized usually and to
have the kids
passports and birth certificates yeah it
can become so emotional so quickly
what's the best way to deal with an ex
who doesn't
want to allow travel well sometimes they
might have a valid
reason if you've threatened to say hey
i'm taking the kids back to my parents
country or my home country and i'm not
bringing them back you're never going to
see it again
well these are valid concerns and
threats so
if you deny your ex the ability to leave
the country to take your kids out of the
country
the only way they can do so is with the
court order so they'll have to
ask the judge to to hear the case and
say hey i want to take my kids to visit
family
in germany or in mexico or another
country
and my ex will not allow it so then the
judge has to decide if it's reasonable
to allow this or not
a lot of times if you are found to
unreasonably deny this request then you
might have to pay
your ex's attorney's fees for having to
file the motion to argue this
uh and bring this in front of the judge
so if you're going to deny it make sure
that you have valid points valid reasons
for doing so
if not it's best just to communicate
well with your ex
and try to be reasonable and always
think of what's
the well-being of the kids yeah
hopefully everyone has an enjoyable and
peaceful summer that way
eric always good to talk to you thanks
for joining us thank you for having me
you can get more information by giving
er palacios and associates a call that
phone number seven zero two
four four four seven seven seven seven
also you can visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com
jc